sammarinese benvenuti lunghissimo questa
questa variazione sul tema e perché è il
primo ufficialmente il primo video a
tema di natalina nathalie stati più che
di natalizia non c'è nulla niente
vediamo vediamo bene adesso che ci sia
ma questo è un outfit natalizio nero un
cerchietto visto che mi è arrivato un
calendario dell'avvento di quelli
proprio irresistibili e ho fatto un
sondaggio su instagram tra l'altro se
non mi seguite se non ci seguite
seguiteci vi ho chiesto se mi sarebbe
piaciuto un video con questa cosa qui
venete torrisi e quindi calendario
dell'avvento di american francia grazie
per il cancro anzi perché ci farai
sicuramente acquisire delle calorie in
più ma bando alle ciance direi di aprire
anche dove l'uno eccolo eccolo iniziamo
a fare proprio un genoa l'ha sì ecco lo
volevo cosa sono era un cioccolatino
immagino a forma di campana
oddio se cosa c'è dentro ma catania no
burro d'arachidi
[Musica]
burro d'arachidi e caramello mammamia
iniziamo bene
va beh non ha idea di cosa
di cosa lo facciate lo baido hard
anonime caricando è una piacevole una
piacevole sorpresa massa di mensa di me
ma io pensavo a qualcosa di zuccherino
di fragoroso al fallimento vabbè diciamo
posso dire che dopo il cioccolato bello
intenso ci siamo sciacquati la bocca e
si va avanti o caramelle tutti frugale
ovviamente da hogwarts fragua ma era
rossa una volata un po questa più grossa
a grazie e tipo il materasso e maurice
agosti è il materasso rovinare
l'esperienza
io dico che edoardo plus donerà tornerò
sicuramente oddio sopraggiunge
i bond in un buon posto si possa dire
affaccia finalmente salato c'è dal rais
e voglia io ne provo una era giusto così
no dai buona buona quando una cosa buona
che daniel o è solo 14 sponde solo 1
eduardo è di buona forchetta e su word
perché non voglio togliere il cibo a
nessuno sa davvero no vabbè queste io
sono felice perché i do rito sono quelli
che mangia tutte volte quad in america
allora ognuno ha un jolly per
abbandonare qualcosa
lo ha deciso ora non me l'aspettavo
suoniamo il suo impulso indirizzo become
the clouds tanto lemonade misseri no
vabbè non me la sento
non è vero
ok spray no va bene sto facendo
diventare acini è quel gusto dolce anche
aspetti anche un numero siamo arrivati
noi purtroppo oddio mi piace questo
salto dolce salato di fonzie colorati
come camicie cioè non piano le paratie
di tanti me la sono quelle forma giose
mazza che io spero che sia il 20 qualche
al 24 ci riusciamo ad arrivare raises
peanut butter tri
ma c'è l'albero di natale ok perfetto
beh no fai mette a metà bella bella
sono a dieta bella coerenza il caramello
e olio ti piace il modo di 100 bureau
della tbm non ispirate alla vita
arrivare una sicura di anarchy
sarà meglio mm buono ma due parole con
caramello diamo a questi rientrano
sicuramente nella top 3
i multi cosa con tagliato no no vabbè mi
meraviglia perfetto questa volta sola
dopo questo bellissimo ricordo
d'infanzia questo gusto puoi utilizzare
un secondo jolly ok va bene così ora
beh oddio forse ho capito io li prendevo
quando ero piccolo non è andata marcia
ma erano veramente buoni non lo so sono
dei pezzi di zucchero probabilmente
quindi che l'ora ris nel 16 ceri snaps
rangers trance pino spino team di buster
amore allora pino di batteri che piace a
te e questa è il collega ma voi cari
amici in anticipo intanto io intanto a
pro 17 che un groove cake che si chiama
hostess e nel xviii ci sono questi due
che sono le solite i suoi di bastoncini
di caramella cioè quando è giusto è
giusto dobbiamo assaggiarli anche se un
pezzettino perché devono capire se tu mi
dici immagina di sono prendere una
saponetta e assaggiarla io ti dico sa di
questo
faccio scambio etico che loreo mi piace
però questa copertura visto ren cat
buono regalo di compleanno e aiutato in
realtà e compleanno ad un uomo giusto
perché le citavo prima harry potter
berti box beans c'è quella nera sadis
porto in che senso
no questo è marrone e poi fatto
veramente anche vomito ma scusa ma ci
sono solo per madonna fa schifo questa
poiché i test che l'odore
cos'è che hai mangiato forse quella
verde però non sono così tanti sapori il
genero perché aveva mangiato 7.000 robe
prima forse poi donarla saggerà i
bookies m m m's ben sanno un po di
salato non sembrano le walter belli pop
tarts tartine poi il cioccolato ragazzi
non me la sento
abbiamo il 23 vediamo così i botti
finali vai la vista che cos'è non è vero
tenendo lo zucchero a velo
ma è cotone ma non schiacciarlo ultimo
orlo di tamburi cioè una barretta è
giocato alla menta a me non piace la
milano si è proprio menta pulce non
capisco perché della barretta resa per
diventa è un h è una città ma poi che
tradisce proprio il colore che avrà di
frutti di voi fate giocare quando l'ho
presa lo analizzata perché prima ho
visto la foto che ho letto mint cioè
unboxing del camera lamento finito
malissimo però devo dire che è stato
divertente perché fate questi dolci o
lamenta direi primo posto molti i tre
secondo posto il poker caramellosi amo
terzo posto non i doritos purtroppo
perché non la smetti dirottare ma devo
dire che questi cookies e yemen
non male fai la tua allora primo posto
reo
sicuramente poi questo che sappiamo
proprio di burro d'arachidi mi è
piaciuto un sacco che secondo bossi e al
terzo posto questi non tanto per il
gusto ma perché osiris e ricordano alla
protagonista del tipo la mia infanzia
fateci sapere qui sotto nei commenti se
anche voi avete un calendario
dell'avvento edoardo si sta prosciugando
il mondo primo video di natale fateci
sapere se vi è piaciuto fateci sapere se
avete condiviso insieme a noi gioie
dolori questo questo video ringraziamo
america ancora che e basta ci vediamo
prossimo video natalizio che stiamo per
girare dopo di questo sei pronto non
vedo l'ora
ciao
[Musica]